[Music]
it's shame my hand so we're
we jumping in anytime soon I was fun at
a worst but it forget it yeah welcome
back to these gentlemen know they're oh
so good to be there it is I thought
we're going to let that song run for
about 18 minutes I know Georgia oh
you're a hilarious
thank god you're so funny full studio
today my friend always good to be with
you I love it you run a sick animal and
I feel not sick not sick at all brought
a sick animal from the children that's
not true
doing great over there right Aaron
sleeping and there's no it has no tail
we just kind of changed earlier tonight
you shaved a hell no it looks like a rat
tail deep unlike yourself I'm busy
helping the community their dogs not
getting adopted oh you trust me well got
a cone on its head yeah it just got
neutered you should get one of those why
do they put the cone on that so he
doesn't look at the balls that's
honestly the truth Tony Austin you need
a call on your left hand and your right
hand you need a cone on two hands so you
stop touching yourself we have a guest
or did your Kel nail again today he's
calling okay how are you by the way what
do you think great obviously did you get
a bonus the past weekend now again I got
anger a very bitter I'm bitter look I am
a little disappointed I'm a little upset
right I'm looking at that haircut aside
to get air guys you cut your own hair
get out no I get it always looks happier
what do you think you like my idol
I think everybody's good everywhere all
that I got yeah Patrick's not ashamed to
admit that he goes where'd he go great
clips I went when we're in San Diego I
think it was super cut you went to super
class yeah yeah yeah what do you throw
back for something like that what each I
mean that's what do I he wouldn't make
it's usually 20 and then you three $4
tips okay the good conversation or they
leave you alone okay like well the flow
B was a great investment you think you
think that's a good price for that cut I
like it I got well I mean I if I can
find a local person like not a local but
a guy that won't handle I want yeah
that's what I want but yeah we're on the
road so much and it's scary I should get
a haircut and so it's usually and
sometimes places that don't take cat
credit cards yeah it's like a men pair
time here in LA is a very very
overpriced is it over yeah okay
yeah I listen I obviously have TV money
I can you know go to a salon I'm sure
you go to the same person then yeah I
mix it up sometimes that people come to
my house
I just depends yeah and I got uh you
know Jimmy Carter used to have a Spanish
barber because he wanted to practice his
Spanish from 76 to 80
yeah oh so that's what his Gary should
have a comedian cut his hair whoa whoa
boss
boom hello ha ha ha well we're excited
today Stephen and saturated oh yeah yeah
we have on a good buddy who I just saw a
couple weeks ago when I was down in San
Diego for comic-con
hold they were doing a yes go to have a
fixed yeah what well that's a fantastic
let's start arguing online yeah Stevie
will be calling in um so we have a guest
on our show today who is part of the
Impractical Jokers team which is one of
the huge hits on truTV fantastic show
fantastic show I was just down in San
Diego for Comic Con doing Conan and and
Brett's well Joker's had a big block
party down there and they were doing
this block party at Petco field
oh wow Padre Padre play yeah it was
packed just packed with all of their
fans that's incredible they were doing
these meet and greets they were doing
these just very cool experiences with
them you could you know do cool things
interactive with them and I got to tell
you it was just it was absolutely all oh
so hey what's gone up buddy what's up
buddy
well we got to give them a proper
introduction okay why aren't you going
down there soon well I said I was just
mentioning that we saw a couple weeks
ago my wife and I were down at comic-con
and you guys did this event for all of
your fans at Petco absolutely it just
blew me away and it was absolutely
packed in there and you guys did this
whole day experience it was absolutely
amazing 1/4 of the Impractical Jokers
how about a round of applause everybody
first I'll walk down now good to have I
got to tell yourself very good get there
it's real life persona is much different
than his feet
that issue area is a very don't don't be
fooled don't be fooled Facebook Gary is
very sweet oh yeah man he can't be a
very sweet man is so sweet he brought it
overnight he'll turn on you quick on
just turn on you quick don't leave don't
leave yourself vulnerable with a post
coke now yeah steve is a little upset
with me that i brought in a rescue dog
because I like to help people and you
know the dogs just trying to get
comfortable Steve's about getting the
getting comfortable means it almost
threw up in the middle of the studio law
introduction so well vomit vomit vomit
makes Gary comfortable when I let home
it's what his wife does every time she
sees in life
so so the way I met you and I love this
I love the story it may be a little
long-winded but when Sullivan & Son the
first season was on Joker's was on we're
both doing the TBS Festival in Chicago
that's the first time we actually hung
out and Owen and I are at the bar like
oh those are the those are the Joker's
and then own goes no they're the
tenderloins they did a ton of sketch
stuff online next thing I know we're
having shots we're drinking and then you
guys are on the road we're on the road
we keep zigzagging we meet up we booze
it up first season everybody's great
second season you guys are starting to
do theaters we're still in comedy clubs
third season you guys are out of the
comedy clubs doing doing theaters we're
still in the comedy clubs on second I
don't think we're getting renewed here
no force no for season and look at this
scale the height you guys have ascended
it's I mean do you guys still I know
you're going into your seventh season do
you still ever there's God like when
you're at Petco for example and Gary's
talking from say and people do you guys
still I you can't be numb to it right
that you keep ascending new and new
heights you're going to London to the o2
arena are there still times where you're
shocked at the success of this every day
shock never get used to it I still don't
believe it it doesn't really feel like
it's happening to us or I can speak for
myself me it just feels like I kind of
watching and looking from the outside in
because nothing about me and my daily
life
it's really changed I mean yeah I could
uh afford more rent now but like you
know my dealer like I'm sitting at home
right now on my couch in my pajamas my
pajamas I'm a hole in them I just say
free cheese out of the tub
[Laughter]
so I you know but you know you know
everything's the same you know with us
put it skin is crazy and someone's like
I still can't like I'm like why I wonder
what that would be like that happened to
me it's like I'm I feel like I'm on the
outside but you're also being very
humble because you are incredibly
successful and the one of best comedians
and Gary I love you too buddy yeah so I
don't know if the met Patrick team but
Patrick Keane is our third co-host on
the DOJ's Patrick hello hey how are you
man formally introduce you guys but I
want to ask you this and I think this is
why the show is still successful it's
not a show we're like Pawn Stars after
wire like alright I get it the you know
there's a format to the show how much
you guys keep reinventing things and the
fact that the hectic wins shaved his
head and Murs gotta wear quinn hair
could be one of the [ __ ] funniest
things I started leaving on any show in
a long time I think that's one of those
things that the guys from jackass must
be going why didn't we think of that
that's genius and you guys keep
reinventing the wheel it doesn't get old
you keep pushing the boundaries I you
know it's a testament to not only you
guys but I would assume your writers
right oh I understand absolutely thank
you so much for saying that oh that's
the goal hopefully we'll pull it off
with lot of fun doing it yeah once in a
while an idea like that like shaving to
bruit hair do you want to shave his head
like a year ago just cuz he was tired of
having long hair yeah and then we got
the idea and we went to the wig maker
and they said it had to be a certain
length which meant that he had to grow
his hair for another year Wow
if we only do it that is a commitment
yeah he committed and then you know
moral court didn't know his fate and we
have to keep that one figure for like a
year but then we're just so happy with
this idea because like you said it was
like you know can i play
as the first season we had 17 episodes
me firstly I was like well that's it
nice run we had there's no more jokes to
behave and I guess if you just kind of
lock yourself in a room and absolutely a
testament to the guys and girls who
write with us over the years where we
just kind of say look you know no you
know this is the same idea so you know
like we're not going to do it again and
let's keep pushing until something we
call them you know we say till we break
our own format so like every season we
try to break our own format in some way
so that people are not necessarily
seeing the same thing in David they
always seem and that one was just
wonderful especially that it was a long
term punishment of Murray for me yeah
and it's funny cuz you had to work you
here for about five months
Wow straight straight to the summer in
every single um in the summer I oh yeah
but so why do you think I mean listen
what before you guys premiered there
obviously was a bunch of hidden camera
shows the people doing what you guys
were doing
why did yours hit and why did it hit so
successfully um well I think first I
think we tweaked the format a little
that made it a competition number one
that made it not just about fooling
people and then moving on there was a
motivation of all a competition there's
a spirit to it we wanted to push and
make sure that we represented our four
different characters that so people
would be rooting for us make sure the
show had heart I think we also want to
make sure that we could fail on the show
and find a way of making us failing
being funny these are some elements that
I don't know if I recall and another
like quote-unquote prank show we really
don't like I know we are we are a prank
show for sure and that's definitely
where we get called we get recalled a
reality show a prank show but at the
heart of it I don't think we're either
of those things I if anything is just
like a kind of a social experiment show
between friends it's more of a showcase
of like our French
it and then just being like completely
ridiculous you know what I mean cuz it
is it is kind of about like us and not
who were pranking you know what I mean
so I know like Punk tight elaborate
pranks that was a whole nother different
level it was like very elaborate about
pranking one specific person and then
candid camera was like which is the God
saw the you know the king of everything
probably the most famous quote unquote
prank show of all time I loved it and we
we we we kind of try to extract an
element of what made candid camera good
and then apply ourselves to it and a new
twist on it so it wasn't just about like
the repetitiveness of even though I
could watch stuff like that and are just
funny home videos I could watch that
stuff all day but but it was it was just
kind of like for me it was like okay
there was it just it was kind of OneNote
and we you know we have a lot of failed
we've been we've known each other for 20
almost 28 years now we perform in comedy
together for almost 18 years so for us
it was about trying to we had so many
failures before this and just trying to
find an outlet that we thought could
showcase our strengths because a lot of
times we get a project and it would be
like the first time we ever had to write
something like this so there and it was
like alright well we're learning through
all this go what about if we thought of
an idea that was plug and play where we
can hit the ground running because we
already know how to be ourselves we
already know how to improvise with each
other and so somehow over a lunch the
idea Clifton and its really evolved over
the years because when we first made the
show wasn't what it is today so it was a
learning process but I guess people
respond to our friendships really well
it's a long-winded answer I just decided
to give you know I think I think the
reason it succeed is you guys weren't
cast yeah you know I you're watching for
friends the camaraderie I think that's
why everybody gravitates toward that's
why I gravitated against eat in Hammonds
really slightly yeah it's not a just for
dudes [ __ ] around with it yeah they're
not for separate bookings for separate
agents Morley careers that you guys are
worried about yeah scheduled yes that is
feedback we get a lot which is you
remind us exactly a lot of friends I
have friend just like you you know we
could we could have had your show you
guys aren't special that's a great point
it is I think the pranks are secondary
to you guys being for likable dudes
that's it yeah it's it's it's like you
said the chemistry it's you know if I
always had a wedding one I was at a
wedding one flyer I had a few drinks
prove it
this guy had a few drinks that he saw
it's like get a little open with me and
he's like yeah love the show rama and
then his nephew he was like it's not if
I could this is never a good time when
they're like I could be honest on those
so it's good like if I could be honest
no offense she goes uh
I mean you got lucky like it's like I
could do any of my anyone could kind of
do it you guys do it right you just turn
the cameras on and I was like yeah I
guess okay that's when you go to him you
go now you couldn't do it because I'm
likeable yeah yeah yeah what you know a
dude yeah unbelievable
I used to get that all the time at
Sullivan & Son they're like hey I'm a
shitty actor and it's like well I mean
but that doesn't matter okay talking to
so it just gut reaction I say I say the
name the first word that comes to your
mind okay Murr Oh God with that Murr
first word that comes to your mind
ha ha ha ha ha Guillory um Murr I the
first thing that keeps my was pain in
the ass ha ha ha all right I'm on Quinn
uh Jesus oh uh I don't know I don't know
could I now big in the winds I treat and
I thought reckless but Quinn's not
reckless yeah so I don't know maybe on
the show he's a little bit of loose
cannon and I mean are we talking like
show wise they're like real life one
just just knee-jerk reflexive ly first
where the comes Joe luna-chick years
worth it yeah but but amongst the
amongst all four of you what is the one
attribute that each one of you brings to
the show if you could describe the
positive attribute that each person
brings to the show that that that makes
it such a well-oiled machine well I get
let's just start with Joe yeah you know
I think we don't have like some
predominant um traits or qualities in
each of us that are pretty different
from the next guy which makes for a good
it's complimentary it makes for a good
like juxtaposition I think Joe really is
and we've said this before but like Joe
is just he's also Wally sees he's really
loud
he's loud but in the in the most in the
funniest way now like obnoxious yeah
he's kind of like um just balls to the
wall
I just got busting lis funny like he
just he's the type of guy he has a
quality that I described like almost
like to me like a Will Ferrell's oh my
god where he doesn't have to do a say
much to have me spent over I don't know
if he is it I bent over laughing or bent
over
it depends what night but on okay okay
another but I did Joe Joe has I did the
way that his face was designed
hahahahahaha first design people you've
got like you've got like you
thousand-yard stare look like he has
like sometimes I shadow on greatest he
embraces his belly and his nose but he
just gets it just look at me and not say
one word and I will literally appear
streaming down my face
no that's the quality that I don't think
it's a Jesus like I almost like a an
intangible that he has that I just think
like we all feel that way and I'm sure a
lot of those people who watch do so yeah
Joe is just you know this city's just
and what's the attribute Quinn and amber
bring to the show by the way Joe is the
Bert Kreischer of the Joker's he loves
taking that shall we go yeah Joe Scott
material yeah he leads he made peace he
made peace with that body long before I
do so you owe to junior high high school
where did this friendship begin with all
for you
uh freshman in high school well III all
like United I always wonder with you
guys to uh sell are you ever out
somewhere just by yourself on a Saturday
and maybe you're getting bed service
somewhere or somebody's messing with you
and you're like I might be [ __ ] with
right now or do you really attribute it
to hey this is really bad right now
so I get it I have a few different
things that recur to me all the time one
is no matter where I am if people stop
me they automatically think they're on
the show Oh funny now filming yoni but
really like two-thirds of my life is not
on Chuck like but most of my free time
people walk up to me if I'm in a store
of them in a Target or they just like on
high alert
they think I'm gonna do something that's
crazy and no not and then the other part
of it is yeah I mean like you know we
talked about how the show kind of
evolved in the beginning we didn't
really like do things where we'd mess
with each other and I'll personalize it
over the last couple of seasons we've
we've set that precedent cross that
boundary so like they trapped me in an
elevator one time they told me that the
Department of Homeland Security I went
to court it was fake record I thought I
was getting through you know I thought I
was gonna have to go to jail or pay a
fine from Department Homeland Security
so they've done things to me like that
so so now every once in a while if
something is slightly suspicious
I do take pause for a second and I'm
just like you know let me just make sure
this isn't like something you know it's
and we have a we have some stuff in the
works like that and we've been planning
for a while for the other guys too which
of course I it's group of me to mention
is I can't say what it is but I could
tell you guys all fair okay I do love
the fact that everywhere you go people
think hey is this being filmed in my
entree later just trying to get a time
oh yeah guys you wouldn't you wouldn't
believe it guys it's such a blast so
this is what I genuinely respect about
you is that of all the guys you're
you've gone full you're in the deep end
with stand up yeah I mean any minute you
have time away from the guys you're
hitting the stage you go on the
festivals you're doing the work you're
in the clubs what is it about stand-up
that that I mean because most guys in
your situation would just be like you
know what I've grinded it out all these
episodes I'm taking a breather you are
hitting the gas and you're going to mind
at all you're just for last year moon
terrier skank fest what is it about
stand-up that has elicited this passion
for from you yeah because I did
everything in Reverse and I'm fine with
that
but I wanted to be a stand-up comedian
turns out was a little kid and I'd
really follow through with it like in
college I did a little bit but not
really and I it was this thing that
always hung over my head and I just was
always like I should be doing stand-up I
should be doing stand-up like I wish I
started at 18 20 you know I'm 40 and it
was like I let years and years pass by
knowing that that's all I ever wanted I
can only be thankful that I finally did
it now and I can't look back and say
what if you know but uh but I was
fortunate enough to have success or
another outlet and um you know have a
little financial security now where I
can dive into it and not worry about
although that's not even it because I I
should have been doing it all as
bartending way back when - and all that
stuff but I just I love it it's my dream
it's all I ever wanted to do it's weird
because like not a lot of people know
what they want to do whatever but for
some reason I knew Olli that's what I
want to do and I'm just making up a long
time now because I love doing it I love
the grind I love the challenge I love
the successes and failures of it just
like every comic you gotta have
something in you don't want to be a
stand-up comic and you know and I just I
I just I just love it the challenge and
like such as something better than
figuring out a joke and making it better
and understanding why it's funny and
then getting that immediate reaction
from people on stage and it is fun and
then what happened is you keep time you
end up keeping time in friends with all
these other like-minded people or the
funniest people on the planet become
your friends and it just you just
it's like a family you know it's
unbelievable like i-i-i I like to go out
and get up every night like I've been up
every night this week like 300 times a
night yeah we're on vacation but like I
mean vacation from the show is really
the only time I can well not really I
can't really go hard like I'm doing like
like a few every night and but it I just
as much to get in there and see my
buddies and like you know I can and I
love you know watching them do their
thing and he's loved submerging myself
and so I'm just making up for all the
old oh well time I'm just I really I've
something to prove to myself well you
know and by the comedy community has
definitely embraced you at the beginning
though was there some sense of like was
it like some backlash because of the
success you've had on the show and you
know you're you're all of a sudden get
any spots at all these clubs with where
they're comedians that kind of looked
looked at you sideways like oh this is
another guy that's on a show that's
going to do stand-up or was it just
immediate like like most guys I know
love you
they not only love you from the show but
they loved it what your standup is as
well I mean did you face some sense of
backlash when you're first starting or
was it was everybody pretty welcoming I
was so so lucky I think I've seen other
people who've done shows and I think it
may be their hearts not in the right
place I don't know but I suspect maybe
like it's like look I can put ads and
see I can fill this club up this weekend
I'm gonna get on stage I'll talk through
it you know and I'll that's all I need
to do or I'll get better eventually or
I'm doing it for a paycheck or whatever
I mean it doesn't really matter in clubs
don't care either if someone's going to
fill up a club you're going to put them
on the stage and I've seen that
criticism of people that maybe like they
don't want they want maybe they want to
try it a lot of people try stand-up
comedy I see people try god I mean they
got up once and then they tell people
they're a comedian which is insane
because you can't they made a whole
social it's called Facebook they my
whole thing about they have a business
card from your different because but I
didn't know if those people truly want
to be comedian but like I I want to be a
comedian
I want to be a good comedian and I want
to leave a mark of the comedian and I
mean I was really lucky because I had a
lot of comics friends over the years cuz
I owned a bar and I was at a comedy
night and I was also in comedy like
sketching improv so I was around it and
I had a lot of friendships early and
then the success of the show comedians
really took two Impractical Jokers
oh yeah and through social media and
Twitter and and things like that
I started befriending more and more
comedians and even hanging with them
before I was getting up and I had a
really nice base of friendships as
communities on the east and west coast
and and then when I first started to do
it like I I don't want to take a spot
that I know I shouldn't get and I didn't
and I guy I just I know part of me wants
anyone to feel like I jumped ahead of
them because of my status or I cut them
I just want my material to speak for
itself
so before I even like took any even
slightly quote-unquote medium profile
shows like just even performed it like a
comedy cover I did a lot of work just
like you know in bars and in like just
whatever spaces just to to know that I'm
not going to get up before I feel that I
know I have something that's funny
that's going to make people laugh and I
could build from that so I really tried
not to prematurely do anything I wish I
still kind of do right now I try not to
UM it's interesting now because when I
saw you a couple weeks ago when you guys
were in San Diego for comic-con I just
remember how busy your schedule was and
you're like hey I definitely want to
come out and do your show I'm gonna try
and catch the end of the first show and
then can I do the beginning of the
second because I need to get back out
and do something for the Joker's it was
crazy because for all the something
going on and when I saw you come in to
do the show it was amazing just how much
more polished you had gotten from the
year before when I saw you last
oh thanks so much yeah great now sure
you have to feel that in the work yeah I
appreciate that yeah I mean oh I was so
I mean I'm thrilled to do to do the show
thank you for inviting me like I
I I won't turn down the show you know
like III I'm so happy to be invited to
be part of it and just to get any kind
that I can fill in because I don't have
a lot of time so anytime someone offers
me something it's like oh wow like
that's an opportunity that I didn't have
before so you know I I just you know and
then I'm also like wow like you know you
know I'm just so happy to be part of it
you know guys you're sure you can you're
an established comedian that that was a
Collider showcase and then all of a
sudden I find myself in the middle of
that and I'm just like I'm just happy to
be invited yeah well you guys you guys
play the the butt of the jokes which is
nice like there are some hidden camera
stuff I won't say any any names or
anything but where it's on the person
that they're putting in the video and
that doesn't give you a good sense of
resolution the great thing about the old
candid camera was you showed afterwards
what the people just got pranked her
Punk'd
he showed afterwards that there was
resolution they were happy it was cool
and everybody feels good with you guys
it's like I mean you guys play the bunt
the the butt of the joke and it's just
hilarious what you do to each other it's
it's it's funny it's funny because it's
like it doesn't feel like we reinvented
much yeah yes you know it's so funny
because you you know you feel like
you've seen it before you know a prank
show hidden-camera show they've been you
know so many of em and you know it's
just funny sec wait a minute has anyone
ever done it this way i guess not and
then it's just like it's so funny that
sometimes there's very simple ideas that
simple ideas on the back i think hey so
I have a couple did everybody ask me
this and I I don't think I've ever
gotten the answer from you about this
when you guys do the show and you go in
and you goof somebody we're right when
do they find out that they're on the
show how does that work it's usually I'm
depending on the location of the
situation so the most part is usually
just moments after we've dealt with them
if they're in a free-form area like
we're on the sidewalk someone's got to
get them quick before we lose them and
they walk away if it's like in the
middle of a speech we gave or something
that's closed off where they're
attending something we'll wait to the
very end because you can't expose it to
anyone else that
you know I mean so it all depends a
little have like a team of people
wearing like they look like secrets like
they look like homeland Secret Service
and they you know they approach and and
take sees again I speak to you over here
for a second we just want to let you
know that this was that and then we just
hope for the best because if the person
doesn't sign you know usually doesn't
work because if the show is based on the
interaction and people's reactions will
stop yeah because I mean you guys are
kind of when you do it you're standing
off to the side watching the monitors
and you can see what's going on from a
distance and you're hoping to get those
people that are distracted kind of
walking in right yeah we we do like we
will scan and be like oh this person
looks like a character and we try to
stack the deck and you know because you
know someone's walking down the street
that looks like some type of you know
whatever they are you know they just
they just look more interesting if it
they're very old or they looked at
dressed loudly or you know they're you
know sheepish or like if they have any
like really strong quality that that's
better for TV because it kind of it
makes it more palpable so I want to ask
you this obviously the show is a monster
success you guys probably had no idea
like you said you're 17 episodes you're
like alright we're done all of a sudden
now you guys are touring you're doing
arenas you did you did where the
Penguins play in Pittsburgh it's one
thing to create a successful television
show for years you guys have been
touring in support of the TV show how
difficult because by now I'm sure it's a
well-oiled machine but how difficult was
it at first to put together the live
show and not only put together a live
show the place in combi clothes but now
you guys are doing arenas
I mean well they have a cruise Chris
Rogers but I mean literally to go from
four guys that are pranking each other
on television to doing a live show
because if these live shows don't catch
on they're not they're not going to
these these people are going to pay to
see them a third and fourth and fifth
time when they go back to these markets
I mean they have such a bright rabid fan
base but you guys keep not only
reinventing the show you keep
reinventing your live show so how
difficult it
that as well to to have four guys that
probably never really been on stage
before now all of a sudden you're
commanding an arena yeah I mean well the
guy that I used to do improv and sketch
comedy in small theaters like from way
back when so we've been on stage
together and we've been in front of
quote-unquote people together but it's a
different animal different beasts we
never did like our version of like
stand-ups
so to speak or whatever it has and we've
gotten better like I know that when we
first started we took a flyer on it well
okay when we get back on stage I mean if
any people come to see us now that the
show's out why don't we piece together
something and just try to get on stage
and see how we feel about and see if we
can evolve it and what it will become
and we started off we have like you know
we're now down to like maybe 10 bullet
points of ideas stories topics of the
show is that the other and we started
new small little comedy clubs like in
Iowa and stuff and we did like a week
and you know by the end of that week
seven days in a row by the end of the
week to show that evolved and when you
join you I mean we're starting with a
bowl of clay there you know and we were
just like you know the people aren't
they don't know what to expect from us
so we know how to improvise and talk to
them and you know they're there to see
us so we think we could at least
entertain them or we weren't like let's
walk out there and crush and we have
polished material but we just kind of
went out and I'm positive if I watch
anything from like our first year it
probably sucks but um but you know the
audience it was good enough for the
audience at least and it was growing and
we were making it better and as we went
and it's actually that you bring up
seeded for me in my opinion it's the
hardest task that we have out of
anything that we do to live share of the
live show it really shows up because now
especially now indictable you said like
we it has to be a certain atmosphere
certain quality and we don't have the
like the benefits of let's say us like a
solo comic like to get up you know a few
nights a week and a few times a night
and listen and play it back and change
it and and have autonomy and whatever
you're doing so you know that you want
to go in this direction
we're doing a stage show by democracy
and we're doing it while we filmed 10 to
11 months out of the year and while
we're still touring 90 to 100 gates
enemy yes so like it's weird because
when they want to put up for theater on
sale it has to go until like six months
in advance that's right so when we're
winding down it's like 18 months of
touring we're on third iteration of
touring right now so we usually do about
a 75 minute show so this is our third
new show raises and when we're winding
down to the end of playing all the
market and it's time to start writing
again the thing that gives me major
stress and anxiety which I don't know
like I do it again is that they put the
fear on sale and six months or now for a
tour that and material that literally
does not exist Wow and then we're under
the gun to get like 75 minutes of
material while we're filming and touring
the old material oh my god yeah and then
they like I said it's like okay fine
everyone has everyone has lives and
families and jobs out there everyone has
but like I can't come home and say hi to
my family and then work on my own jokes
in my house because I we have to do it
together so you know that's not this
part that gets me like really sick to my
stomach because I want the show to be to
a certain standard and so what we do is
we we don't we do these we call them
podcast shows there's a podcast is cool
because it sets up a certain expectation
from the audience that we're going to be
shooting [ __ ] free form it'll be
conversation there will be necessarily
hysterical so they come to see a live
podcast and we do like two a night
90-minute each time and then we do about
20 of those so now get rerecord and we
record the video so we record like 40
hours of us riffing on stage doing
podcast shows and then we take that back
and we go through all of it and break
down that could have been a bit that
could be it
oh my god yeah that's great yep and then
we narrow that down and then we do more
and targeting those bits and to our
developer that's the only way we could
do it but it is it is in the middle of
everything else so you also start to
feel mentally kind of like you know
creatively
type a little because like you can't run
your brain that much you know what I
mean because there's so much emphasis on
the TV show but these live shows there's
no editing Bay
there's the you're literally performing
in front of 1516 thousand people it's
like you got it you got to hit your mark
so for me as not only a friend of yours
but as a fan of all you guys obviously
um to me that is so commendable that you
guys keep grinding it out on the road
and you keep coming up with new material
collectively as a group it's a Herculean
task
there a is there a Yoko Ono that's going
to break you guys up is there a woman
just gonna come in and mess everything
up are you guys getting along I was just
saying there's got to be like you guys
tour together so much you're sitting at
home by yourself on a Friday you know or
is there any thought of you that's like
yeah call up Murr see what he's doing
tonight's he wants to grab a drink
there's probably no thought to that ever
Jesus Christ no you rather just sit like
you're not calling I'll try no nobody
wanted to hang out now it does it does
completely go both ways like we are so
lucky that we get the tour together I
mean yes we are with each other almost
24/7 yes because we film the show all
week long and then on Friday we get on a
plane together I know with each other
all weekend long so we're with each
other literally we probably will each
other nine out of ten days and it's a
blessing and a curse it's a blessing
because you guys know it it's lonely
alone on the road on the poor side of a
highway you know so we get to do that
and then you know when we're on the road
together though you know we definitely
like hey you want to go to a movie and
they want to do this or that and when
and the few times that we do have a few
weeks apart for each other you know you
are you're also like I I'll be excited
to you guys but when we get little break
I think we all feel like we just need to
yeah to our own thing right absolutely
well so we can I know you're heading to
a dinner we cannot thank you enough for
taking the time to call it again I know
you're swamped
enjoy your downtime you you do not it
this is the no big deal and I'm so happy
to call are you kidding me by the way
thanks don't thank me
can I ask you one last class
my grandma is a big fan of the show or
he said hey ask them uh how much [ __ ]
they get Carrie and I'm just like okay
I'll ask but my grandma I'm sorry Carrie
you're breaking up I decide so we love
you from we cannot thank you enough for
calling in Carrie John teller unlimited
I and what we've learned from this
conversation today is that Sal field I'm
an established comic so Thank You Sal
that's for is restraining that and
believing in me and I will tell you
right here's what I love about Sal he's
running around running his ass off
entertained by 15,000 people a color
comic-con making sure everybody's happy
my wife and I are kind of backstage is
hanging out enjoying this White Castle
truck that was there on the field the
greatest thing ever and you go over to
show like hey you guys need anything can
we do anything about my wife kind of
made a joke and said hey I'm cold and
you're like I'll get you a sweatshirt
look what are you talking about like
just so generous and overextending
yourself to make sure everybody else was
having a good time it was so amazing so
thank you for that but thank you for
your friendship you guys are hilarious
and obviously I'm so glad that you guys
got to stop by and I'm glad you got to
perform at the madhouse that Friday
night that you guys were there there was
so much fun yeah Casey my truly truly my
pleasure really
so we love you we'll see on the road
good luck season seven right that you
guys are going to start that yeah right
yeah we start writing first week in
September my god god bless you guys
amazing yeah Congrats on every now I
love you guys I love you guys to death
we love you too Sal take care buddy
thank you got me I'll talk to y'all soon
all right bye bud great Paula Poundstone
literally I mean and you could say this
about Sal but you could literally say it
about all for those guys yeah
the nicest guy yeah yeah yeah they
genuinely are all for the nicest dudes
not not one of them has let an ego hit
today hit there that's not like this
podcast no you know it yes and not
accessible that maybe it's good
they have a great live show because
trailer park boys which is I'm a huge
fan of that Nadine series is hilarious
and I love it but seeing them live is a
bit of a train wreck yeah but it's it's
not like what these guys and Patrick and
I know guys that aren't selling tickets
NF huge egos and you know they don't
sell [ __ ] you know they had a TV show
that failed where can they find you see
I'm sure grandma have any questions
right ladies and gentlemen this
concludes another wonderful limo to the
dojo Oh we'll be in Tampa floor together
oh yeah all of us there item contempo oh
yeah okay we don't happen and I do yours
Eve
the three of us do yours easy Adil
Washington I don't around the line para
live
it is one of the best club it's my best
idea yeah so did your that's a pig
where are you here with Paige where can
I find you at citizen teen boom at
Cannon comedy I still don't believe
that's T burn live we are the
gentlemen's dojo find us write a review
rate us run iTunes we love you dojo
[Music]
[Applause]